generalmente el nitrógeno tiene menos
atención que el carbono y el oxígeno
pero el nitrógeno también es muy
importante para la vida y como el caso
del carbono y del oxígeno también existe
un ciclo del nitrógeno en nuestra
biosfera ahora algo muy sorprendente
sobre el nitrógeno si es que no lo han
estudiado mucho es que es muy muy común
en nuestra atmósfera el 78 por ciento de
nuestra atmósfera es nitrógeno molecular
se encuentra en la forma n 2 miren este
es nitrógeno molecular tiene dos átomos
de nitrógeno unidos covalente mente y a
diferencia del carbono que es fijado
directamente por las plantas como vimos
en el vídeo sobre el ciclo del carbono y
explicamos cómo los autótrofos utilizan
la energía luminosa para fijar el
carbono del aire en forma sólida y
almacenan esa energía en los enlaces
carbono carbono
nitrógeno no puede fijarse directamente
por organismos complejos como las
plantas en su lugar el actor principal
que fija el nitrógeno del aire imaginen
que tenemos todas estas moléculas de n12
en el aire aquí los actores no son las
plantas sino las procariotas como las
bacterias entonces déjenme dibujar el
suelo y las bacterias pueden estar en
muchos lugares pero supongamos que
tenemos bacterias en este suelo las
dibujaría un poco más grandes para que
puedan verlas entonces aquí tenemos a
las bacterias y cierto tipo de bacterias
son capaces de fijar el nitrógeno tienen
la capacidad de tomar el n2 y
transformarlo a algo que sea más útil
para organismos complejos como las
plantas entonces esta es una bacteria y
este es su adn podría dibujar lo más
complicado pero vamos a dejarlo así
entonces la bacteria puede fijar el n2
en amoniaco nh3 este es el amoniaco y el
amoniaco es muy útil para las plantas y
otros organismos complejos ahora en el
vídeo del ciclo del carbono hablamos
sobre cómo las plantas fijan el carbón y
que el carbono constituye una gran parte
de las moléculas orgánicas pero muchas
moléculas orgánicas importantes también
necesitan nitrógeno y estos son algunos
ejemplos de moléculas orgánicas que
podemos encontrar en las plantas pero
que también podemos encontrar en
diferentes tipos de organismos miren
aquí tenemos un aminoácido
a mí no ha sido aquí podemos ver el
nitrógeno y por acá tenemos a nuestro
viejo amigo atp adenosina de trifosfato
el almacén de energía en sistemas
biológicos aquí podemos ver el nitrógeno
de color azul y por acá tenemos al
famoso adn ácido desoxirribonucleico y
podemos verlos nitrógenos presentes en
esta macro molécula entonces el
nitrógeno es esencial para la vida pero
ese nitrógeno se fija gracias a las
bacterias que pueden producir amoniaco y
que a su vez puede ser utilizado por las
plantas y claro después al comer las
plantas otros seres como tú y yo podemos
llevar el nitrógeno a nuestros sistemas
ahora esto no ocurre únicamente en una
sola dirección aquí partimos del
nitrógeno de la atmósfera después es
fijado por las bacterias se transforma
en amoniaco y finalmente es utilizado
por organismos más complejos
en algún momento todo eso se cancela si
un organismo muere supongamos que aquí
tenemos un organismo muerto podría ser
una bacteria pero vamos a poner un
organismo multicelular esta es una
planta muerta
no quiero dibujar animales muertos
porque eso es más impactante entonces
supongamos que esta es una planta muerta
y cuando se descompone existen
diferentes tipos de bacterias aunque si
las dibujos se ven iguales pero
supongamos que ésta es otra bacteria
conforme las bacterias asimilan la
planta pueden tomar un poco de nitrógeno
y transformarlo en nitritos y nitratos
estas son moléculas que involucran a
nitrógenos unidos a dos o tres oxígenos
y que pueden regresar al amoniaco
entonces podemos regresar y tenemos una
bacteria que nos lleva nuevamente al
amoniaco o simplemente en algún momento
al convertir el nitrógeno en nitritos y
nitratos podemos volver al nitrógeno
molecular
n 2 con lo que es liberado nuevamente a
la atmósfera o bueno también podría ser
almacenado de otras formas pero en
general este es el ciclo tenemos estos
elementos que son esenciales para la
vida y no desaparecen o se forman de la
nada constantemente son reciclados en
nuestra biosfera y el nitrógeno no tiene
tanta atención como el carbono y el
oxígeno pero también es esencial para la
vida de hecho cuando estudiamos plantas
en crecimiento y pensamos en los
fertilizantes el fertilizante es algo
que le ponemos a una planta para que
crezca más sin eso de alguna forma se
limita lo rápido que puede crecer una
planta y muchos fertilizantes contienen
nitrógeno en otro vídeo hablamos sobre
el fósforo el fósforo y el nitrógeno y
su disponibilidad en el suelo
generalmente son un factor limitante de
la velocidad del crecimiento de las
plantas y eso lo sabemos porque si
agregamos más nitrógeno o foxo
tendremos más amoniaco en el suelo y las
plantas crecerán más rápido